it's be 3 2015 I'm Justin this is Peter
and we got to see a little bit of a new
zelda game maybe not as exciting as
zelda for Wii U but a new zelda 3ds game
tri Force heroes yeah it's it looks a
lot like four swords well I mean it is
four swords except that this time
they're only three swords so there's a
new mechanic in this game and were you
jump on top of your other lincare drug
lord yeah totem that you're going to
explore around with your able to hit
enemies that are high up able to hit
switches but they were saying with the
developer talking with the developers
that it didn't really work with four
characters so they're limiting this one
two three which is probably why they're
not calling it four swords I don't know
what he means when he says it doesn't
work but you know whatever you're
playing on the 3ds is a small screen and
especially if you turn on the the 3d
effect like maybe it was just really
confusing to have too many characters
like sacked up three does seem like
watching watching it in action as it
seemed like a good number of characters
to have on there sure but you know one
of the other features of the game is
costumes you get to put on different
outfits to gain new abilities and this
kind of reminded me of a link between
worlds where you have the ability to
rent items or items we've seen before
but how that influences you know the
flow of the game and in the different
systems you play with seems very similar
to this where you can sort of take on a
new ability at your own you know free
will and it's very visual when you're
going to be playing with other players
you need to know what other abilities
these characters have and if somebody
has on their bomb suit like you know
that I'll hey this is the guy who has
bombs this is what he's going to be able
to use how easily or how quickly you're
gonna be able to switch between them
we're not totally sure how all of that
works yet but I think it's a good visual
clue as to what's going on and it's I
think gonna be a lot of fun because
there's there's a Zelda costume it's
like they're good they're gonna have
some fun make things maybe a little bit
comical with some of the costumes that
are going to be available what was
really nice for me was to see Nintendo
embrace the idea of online multiplayer
which is something you're going to be
able to do with this game is play with
your friends online I mean that's
something Nintendo you know keeps
dipping their toes in the water to try
out but here they're actually doing its
with his elder game no less and we see
that with a lot of other games coming
out i think monster hunter 4 has been
just a great use case for multiplayer on
a local or an online capacity that works
great I'm glad that Nintendo is finally
jumping onto that bandwagon in it and
producing games that I want to play with
my friends whether they're in the same
room with me or maybe their plane from
home
craziest thing this game is coming out
this fall like a few months from now
Nintendo needed that I mean there's not
a huge slate of games especially with
Zelda getting pushed that is gonna fill
out the rest of this year we were
expecting Nintendo to have at least some
small surprises that let us know what's
coming out for the rest of this year on
Wii U and 3ds we got that during the
Nintendo Direct presentation maybe not
to the level that everyone was expecting
gotten you know new mario game and for
3ds users in new zelda game a new
Metroid kinda game I think Zelda is
probably going to be one of the more
exciting things that we're going to be
able to play on 3ds and you know I I'm
always any excuse to get back into that
Zelda world that's what I want and even
if this maybe it's not a full Zelda
adventure this is going to fill that
void that Zelda Wii U is left well maybe
we didn't hear anything about a new
zelda game for Wii U but at least we're
getting something on the 3ds hopefully
lives up to your expectations for more
news and more related in Nintendo and
the rest of the show stay tuned and
gamespot com / III